make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so so I have I've been posting
about this on social media
and and here's the thing myself and and
Sal oversell says what and and video I
guess a comic pop and the video the
comic story we all have our own things
right like Vinny's the Batman guy Sal's
a spider-man guy I'm the x-men guy I
would I would I'd be able to tell you I
could probably hold my own against like
99.99999% of people out there who read
x-men comics right like I know what I'm
talking about because I've been reading
x-men for that long excellent was like
the first comic book that I cared about
because it was on the first kind of a
show that I ever saw that I cared about
right like I saw x-men the animated
series before I saw Batman which is why
I say x-men is better than Batman one
because it is and two because it is
I've been tracking the x-men for years
like for over two decades right like 24
25 years of reading x-men comics I have
been there through thick and thin I have
seen terrible x-men stories right like
pretty much everything that Jeff Austin
wrote after after Grant Morrison left um
pretty much everything that Chris
Claremont wrote after he left and then
came back so like extreme x-men all that
kind of stuff
um I mean I've read I've read like
amazing stories right like House of M
and and not the onslaught of saga of
that story sucked but like the Phoenix
either the Dark Phoenix saga like even
if I wasn't old enough to be able to
read those comments at the time like
I've read the back issues so like I've
read so much x-men over the years it's
absolutely insane and I would say I'm
probably in the top 1% of people in the
world who can call themselves like an
authority on the x-men and I don't say
that out of arrogance I say it because
it's true because I've just been reading
them that freaking long and so with that
being said Marvel has had like these ups
and downs when it comes to the x-men
right like in the early 1990s it was
like x-men everything right like
everything was the x-men if it had X
slapped on it and if it was part of the
X Universe it's sold that's just the way
it was right like you have the original
x-men by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby didn't
so well they tried to rework in
everything and then Chris Claremont took
over and like that's when it exploded
then you've got new mutants and you got
Generation X and you got x-factor by
Louise Simonson and Walter Simonson
which was originally written by Bob
Layton and you got like like all these
x-men related publications right like X
Factor which was the newest iteration
the government-sanctioned team and then
you get extreme x-men which sucked and
then you get you know ecstatic which
sucked and you get like all these
different things so yeah ecstatics
whatever whatever
it's stupid well you got all these all
these different stories over the years
but like but but with the x-men as a
whole like they're they're probably one
of the probably one of the most popular
and in most interesting and diverse
teams out there right because it's just
like a crazy amount of power in like
such a small group of people we have
mutants but what does that mean it means
we can do whatever we want to because a
plot calls for so they're all basically
like a giant amalgamation of Batman
right like that make him do whatever he
needs to do because a plot demands it
and that's it like I can I can save the
universe because the plot requires me to
and so there we go
like it's it's it's it's kind of crazy
when you get down to it but like hitman
writing the x-men is nuts because in my
mind the x-men haven't really been
interesting or cool for like 11 years
right like since 2008 2009 roughly 2010
so maybe between like 9 and 11 years
like basically everything after Massiah
war is when the x-men lost interest to
me like we got all new x-men which was
like a time this place team who cares
like they they weren't cool when Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby wrote them and they
weren't cool when Brian Michael Bendis
was riding him like it's just it's just
what it is like that nobody cares about
the young excellent nobody cares about a
team that's like pretty white kids with
problems nobody cares about that like
people want to see you like a cool you
know interesting scenario where people
are like struggling and stuff and then
like somebody comes along with some
godly powers and just like wretch like
people want to see that right like
that's like it's like reading The
Incredible Hulk with that The Incredible
Hulk
like basically Avengers endgame like hey
guys you know how you wanted to see that
read that that that rematch between Hulk
and Thanos well you're not gonna get it
instead the Incredible Hulk is basically
gonna be like an Apple store employee
and that's essentially it and so so so
when when I look at Hickman right in the
x-men it's gonna be nuts because my
initial thought were model first
announced it is they said okay so
Hickman is writing house affected powers
of that sounds like okay so basically to
six-issue miniseries so we're gonna get
like a like two six-issue miniseries
rotating by week what does that mean
well it means every two weeks you're
gonna get one of the books so let's say
that like we started now it would mean
like on on today the 14th of Wednesday
that this video is being made that we
would get um that we would get you know
House of X number one and then next
Wednesday we would get powers of X
number one the Wednesday after that we
would get House of X number two and the
Wednesday after that we would get powers
of X number two so basically you get a
Jonathan Hickman
x-men book of the
series like every single week so those
are guys were reading DC think Action
Comics in Superman or Batman and
detective is basically how this would
how this would rotate and I was like
okay so basically two mini series I mean
it'll be cool I kind of wish you would
write the whole x-men book like write
uncanny x-men as a whole and like really
take off with it but I guess I've only
done I'm always gonna do is too many
series it meets a test bed to see
whether or not he can write the x-men or
something along those lines and it's
always like okay cool whatever and I'll
check it out and I'll cover it and
that'll be that and then Marvel comes
out and they're like no that's not what
we're doing we're not doing just to
Jonathan Hickman miniseries we're
rebooting at all like it's all getting
reworked and everything we're canceling
every single x-men team we're cancelling
every single x-men book is all going
away and Hickman's gonna write house of
x powers of X that's going to set the
stage for everything after which
Jonathan Hickman is gonna write here is
the thing here is the thing dude it's
it's gonna be it's gonna be ridiculously
good because people who don't who aren't
really familiar with comics are like
okay why do you like here because it's
gonna be one of the greatest books you
ever read that's why like when Jonathan
Hickman wrote the Fantastic Four he
started off with the Dark Reign
miniseries right which didn't really
have anything to do with Dark Reign
except for like Norman Osborn the Green
Goblin showing up on the doorstep of
like the Fantastic Four and it's being
like so I want to take over the back
stability and I need to talk to the
Fantastic Four and the only person the
only people there we're like I think
Valeri Richards and Franklin Richards
and like maybe Ben Grimm because he's
lazy and just sits around all day doing
nothing like he's daily noob Ingram's
like the laziest person ever like he
never does anything well he just was
like it's clobberin Tom and then he's
like he's winded two minutes into it
he's like he's just fat and lazy and and
and and like anyway so Norman Osborn
goes into the Baxter building and like
and literally like Franklin Richards
runs up on him with like a toy gun like
this little toy pop gun and then pulls a
trigger and it fires a real bullet he
just like fabricated a bullet out of
thin air and then shot Norman Osborn
with it Norman on foam was like okay
yeah so like this was a terrible idea of
all the bad ideas I've ever had this was
like the worst and it was like because I
basically broke into the house of a kid
who can warp reality on a universal
scale
um this kid could turn me into like a
tuna fish he could turn me into like
like I don't know like something
interesting as opposed to just a guy who
talks to voices and it's basically like
a poor man's Joker like like he could do
almost anything to me so I should
probably not like break into this house
and and do this thing like that's that's
it
you really get with the Dark Reign thing
I mean you get like little tie-ins like
little little things here and there like
you basically learned that Reed Richards
is talking to what you eventually
discovered to be the Council of reeds
but like none of that really comes to
fruition it makes sense until you get
into like the main Fantastic Four story
and that's like that's a crazy thing is
because but it's gonna be like this this
awesome crazy cool experience of these
fingers crossed and hope it is I don't
know why it wouldn't be but it's gonna
be like this crazy awesome experience
but here's the thing it's gonna have
like these crazy moments right now
you're gonna have like these crazy
little moments here and there which is
all gonna lead up to something nuts like
something bonkers like I really hope he
does do to like to fill on Apokolips
where he's like okay so we're bringing
up pocalypse back because this guy is
Opie dude let me tell you something our
pocket is so Opie and he's like the one
villain Marvel never knows what to do
with cuz like cuz you know like nobody
really cares enough to figure it out
they tried that like apocalypse wars
crossover event that happened over the
course of like what is it extraordinary
x-men and uncanny x-men and all-new
x-men isn't like that and it was dumb
but like here's the thing dude up Hawk
it looks like if he's written correctly
all dude apocalypse a clean house
dude apocalypse will wreck everybody
you're talking about a guy who subdued
The Incredible Hulk
you're talking about a guy I don't know
if he's ever fought a juggernaut but I
wasn't could ever really stop him either
I mean he's channeling like the power of
the Celestials so maybe I have no idea
but you're essentially talking about a
villain that that a full contingent of
the x-men like a full contingent like
all the x-men on their best day could
not defeat him there was one point it
was it was during the lead-up to - like
to the origin of cable and it was like
it was like Cyclops in the x-factor so I
Cyclops Jean Grey Ice Man beast and
Angel along with like all the all-new
x-men so like Wolverine Colossus and all
those guys teaming up with like be in
humans because whatever and like none of
them could could stop apocalypse like he
basically thought he faced off against
them all like lucky that's happened on
multiple occasions apocalypse is face
off against like the Avengers and the
x-men at the same time and it's all they
can do to hold him off I do this guy is
broken like it's crazy how powerful he
is and if you threw like you you did you
give him the Jonathan Hickman oh dude
apocalypse a clean house did you walk in
there be like okay so like everybody's
gonna die and just and just obliterate
all the x-men just like in one fell
swoop all the x-men are basically gone
it
it would be bonkers dude mr. sinister
knew he could bring back he could do
like angel properly like Warren
Worthington he could do him like like
there's so much he could do with this
like he would he'd probably do it like
where you ended up having like like the
Fantastic Four word run were like some
crazy event happens at the end like
maybe somebody comes back from the
future I don't really know Jonathan
Hickman doesn't usually repeat the same
gag twice and so so like like regardless
of what it is like it would be it'd be
bonkers right like like Holocaust we
already have like darkbeast who's in
existence and as far as I'm aware
there's no reason to believe he's gonna
base anything about what he's doing off
of what with Matthew Rosenberg's doing
right so like Rosenberg is gonna finish
and then it was gonna be like in
whatever that's all back there and he's
gonna draw from like a litany or do I do
the Phoenix force dude okay here's the
thing because hitman with hitman would
do something like this
hitman would come along and say okay so
like we're gonna retell the origin of
the Phoenix force and like we're gonna
go through the origin of the x-men and
we're gonna like retool juggernaut and
we're gonna do like all these crazy
things cuz imagine that imagine like
juggernaut versus of hawk ellipse or
imagine like juggernaut versus like all
the x-men of the feels-like juggernaut
at 100% power which you've we've only
ever seen like two or three times right
we saw eight day juggernaut we saw try
on juggernaut which was where he
basically like punched a hole in reality
and then we saw like like um juggernaut
when he was willing the hammer of scatty
so during like fear itself so so like
we've seen these crazy versions of
characters but like it would be like I
can't imagine we'll just be like some
grand pooh-bah huge thing that happens
at the end worse like some guys behind
it all like the x-men have to face him
you know and like it would turn it would
it would become absolutely bonkers like
who knows but it's I can I can gear I
can guarantee I can't guarantee you a
whole lot of stuff about what it was
gonna do but I can guarantee you this
it's gonna be one hell of a run so like
like Hickman's x-men like House of X
powers of X hits me the Hitman's run on
the x-men team like you need to read
this like I mean I'm definitely gonna
cover it but like you need to read this
because like when this is all said and
done you want to be one of the people
posting on forums or social media or
whatever who are like I follow the whole
thing from start to finish because it'll
be rewarding you'll be like dude like
kills because he'll finish it'll be like
the last issue he'll finish and he'll
put the pin down and you'll close the
comic book and you'll put the comic down
you'll be like dude that was one hell of
a ride and and and like it'll it'll it's
it's gonna be boss like it's gonna be I
mean scene storm at like 100 percent
power where she's just like wreaking
havoc with
entire earth ecosystem here's the thing
storm herself oh let me tell you
something if storm went on a rampage
right like somebody did something crazy
and like killed Black Panther and like
storm just loses her mind right or like
Sonny takes his parking spot she was
waiting on whatever the case says like
if somebody does something that like
just pisses her off dude storm oh dude
she could turn the world upside down I
mean dude let me let me tell you some
man like dude there's a few people out
there in the world who could stop storm
once she like snaps and just and it just
come on okay so like the entire Earth's
ecosystem is gonna go to pieces
it'll be like it'll be like like that
movie what is it the day after tomorrow
except like not environmentalist
propaganda like it'll be it'll be like
um a they would be amazing it would be a
sight to behold but but yeah like
regardless of what happens it's gonna be
boss that's basically what I'm telling
you here it's like hitman writing the
x-men is gonna be insane it's gonna be
one of like the coolest things ever so
ya know maybe we'll drop a DC video
today
why I mean it's it's this is way bigger
than anything DC has going on but uh but
yeah anyway with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here the comments
explained make sure you guys with the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like let me know what you guys
think down in the comments about your
excitement for Jonathan hitman right in
the the x-men and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]